[Musique]
six ans au plan de 32 espèces indigènes
et endémiques de la réunion des mises en
terre ce 9 décembre dans la grande cour
de lagence d'edf à saint pierre une
micro forêt urbaine qui s'inscrit dans
le cadre du plan un million d'arbres du
département c'est un exemple qu'on
souhaite multiplier à travers tout le
département donc ces micro forêt urbaine
l'idée du plan un million d'arbres donc
c'est pas la collectivité départementale
qu'il a planté son premier million
d'arbres tout seul l'idée set fédérer
nos acteurs publics les acteurs
territoriaux au premier rang desquels
les établissements publics donc
aujourd'hui on est chez edf demain on
sera dans des communes des
intercommunalités des associations du
territoire et l'idée c'est de dynamiser
cette démarche là pour pouvoir avoir des
patchs de micro forêt urbaine adapté au
secteur géographique sur lequel on est
ici à titre d'exemple
saint pierre on est sur le milieu semi
sec on n'a que des espèces du milieu ce
mx 0 fils qui seront plantés depuis
plusieurs années le groupe edf s'engage
dans la protection de la biodiversité
cette action est la première déclinaison
opérationnelle de la convention-cadre
2020 2023 avec edf en partenariat avec
la v2 m l'association pour la
valorisation de l'entre-deux monde est
en fait l'opération a commencé en fait
sur de la lutte contre les espèces
invasives c'est à dire que sur ce site
on a hérité comme beaucoup sur l'île de
tulipes y du gabon pour l'heure question
ornementale mais le tulipier du gabon
ben en fait il identifié comme une
espèce une des espèces les plus
emballants invasives ou monde donc la
première action a consisté à les enlever
dans cette veine dizaine de jours est
dans la symbolique en fait de remplacer
cette espèce invasive par des espèces
qui sont patrimoniale endémiques ou
indigènes à la mission de l'association
effectivement c'est la lutte contre les
espèces invasives ou aussi bien au
niveau animales que végétales dans le
but de préserver la biodiversité un mot
même présente des actions nous pour
préserver les oiseaux endémiques de la
réunion les oiseaux marins parlera pour
les prédateurs qui ont été introduits et
là sur ce site là on accompagne prise
par rapport à la protection la
préservation des espèces de commandes de
la flore indigène endémiques de la
réunion quatre classes de l'école de la
seconde chance sont venus participer à
cette opération de plantation les jeunes
ont rapidement pris goût à l'activité
[Musique]